eine ganz normale wohnsiedlung oder vivo
novia sagt geldquelle
wie funktioniert dieses prinzip unter
anderem mit umbauten dass sie jetzt hier
den bau machen und und auf dieses haus
noch eine etage drauf setzen wollen die
sagen es dauert zwölf monate bis es
fertig ist und welche haben angedroht
ist ein vermittler erhöhung gibt also
ich bei meiner grund geben mindestens
250 euro mehr bezahlen muss ja auch mal
die aktionäre denken ja wahrscheinlich
aktionär interessieren wie überhaupt
nicht aber was sagt renaud ghia dazu
haben ich habe jetzt in den letzten
tagen mit einigen mietern gesprochen die
sehr unzufrieden waren mit
modernisierung nebenkostenabrechnung ja
wenn sie uns den namen geben dann
setzten uns gerne mit den mietern
zusammen
das lustige ist viele von denen haben
angst ihre namen zu nennen ja das ist
traurig das ist traurig und dann haben
wir vorwiegend die traurigkeit nicht ab
was haben sie für nebenkosten es wird
ein winterdienst abgerechnet wenn
entweder keinen schnee fällt oder es
fällt schnee
aber es kommt auch kein winterdienst
wann ist denn der winterdienst in der
regel unterwegs der ist nicht morgens um
6 uhr unterwegs sondern der ist morgens
um vier unterwegs natürlich ist es dann
häufig für die mieter in dem haus nie
sichtbar
und dann hat es danach geschneit und
deswegen hat der mieter das dann nicht
mitbekommen und dann am nächsten tag kam
das sehr gute streue unternehmen hat
gestreut dann das ist dann passiert es
hat glauben sie es oder nicht es hat
geschneit
und dann ist der ball via mieter wieder
aufgewacht man das gibt's doch nicht
hier ist ja schon wieder nicht gestreut
worden
wir können mit 119 wie wir haben
interesse daran dass unsere nebenkosten
überhitzen
daran haben wir kein interesse haben für
mich wir sind sehr verlässlich was die
dividenden angeht
in berlin gibt es die idee große
wohnungskonzern einfach zu enteignen
wir testen die stimmung auf dem
deutschen immobilien kongress enteignung
kann jetzt nicht kein kommentar thema
enteignung danke thema enteignung die
leute laufen wirklich kommen wir weg die
ganze zeit hallo schön guten tag thema
enteignung
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass damit die probleme
dieser stadt löste aber es sind ja doch
überraschend viele berliner dafür wenn
sie diese fragen würden ob täglich
freibier geben würde würde es
wahrscheinlich auch dafür stimmen in den
mieter klagen aber ja auch darüber dass
die immobilienkonzerne die preise
unnötig hoch treiben mit falschen
nebenkostenabrechnungen zum beispiel
naja also offen gesagt so gut wie keiner
kann sich in diesem regulatorischen raum
den wir haben anders verhalten als der
gesetzliche rahmen ist vor gibt ja wir
versuchen heute schon mal herauszufinden
wie die immobilienbranche reagiert wenn
sie denn enteignet wird zum beispiel
trägt sie den kaffee noch
also ich wüsste jetzt offen gesagt nicht
warum nicht weil enteignung im sinne von
wetten dass mein café ja ja also den
würde ich jetzt enteignen
wo ich sagen also der preis für diesen
kaffee ist aus meiner sicht gerade mal
15 euro und jetzt lasst uns mal
unterhalten so ist nämlich die
rechtslage
hallo frau kramp karrenbauer ich freue
mich auch sie sind ja gegen enteignung
aber andererseits hat die cdu doch
jahrelang die spd skrupellos enteignet
danke kommt in die lüneburger heide
da kann man noch für fünf euro oder 6
teuren quadratmeter einer wohnung
bekommt man halt in der lüneburger heide
wurden dann in der lüneburger heide
aber wenn man natürlich zu berlin in
hamburg man sich auch gleich erschießen
dankeschön und sie in der lüneburger
heide natürlich sonst hätte ich das
ehrlich gesagt enteignung ist
keinesfalls umsatz bei weil das
widersinnig ist und entgegen jedem song
jeglicher gesellschaftlicher
grundordnung widerspricht und damit
natürlich auch
insofern von uns bzw vordergrund
entsprechend
vorangebracht wird das war klar und
deutlich ja das thema enteignung wird
hier beim immobilien kompass 2009 10
sehr positiv aufgenommen ich glaube dass
es klar geworden und damit zurück ins
studio guten tag könnte ich sie für ein
abo des heute show youtube kann als
begeistern ließ gefälligst ein abo ab